the trunk guy's really good frank guy's
really good man he's one of those hidden
gems that you find in the north american
valley there are always three things
certain in life gusting we talked about
earlier death taxes and trent finding a
way to clutch up oh trying to line up
some shots off the ghost but he's not
able to hit anything ethan already
and he got
it
the position of the other last known in
close single bullet to repeal the wall
back back towards the sidewalk a lean
out for the first one oh what a flex day
off the pancake it's not gonna go down
time is over
oh it's red oh my trends
hey folks before we get into the video i
want to remind you all to please sub to
the channel and turn on notifications if
you haven't done it yet because it
really does help we are super close to 2
million subs and you could be the one
who gets us there yes you okay so if
you've watched any north american
valorant at all this year you've
definitely heard of trent he's the
rising star of the guard's hype roster
and every single time he plays he does
something special that's going to
re-wrap back over trent's going to be
able to surf out some information by way
of this all drone but holding onto the
corner
it's bottom
hunters fury
blindly completely blind recon bolt
comes through mata playing up top
has to go for at least some toggle knows
that mod has to come check this he
guesses correctly and the 1v1 comes
through
there is no way
ty will be close
but trent will get it
i really can't happen
trent is so good at the video game but
trent's journey in gaming started nearly
10 years ago when at just six years old
he was grinding cod zombies with his
brother as he grew older and eventually
made the switch to pc trent got hooked
on rust but in april 2020 one of his
friends recommended the valerian beta
and almost immediately trent turned his
focus to riot's new tactical shooter
we started playing and
i was pretty good at the beginning and i
just wanted to be really good because i
like i'm really competitive and i try to
push myself and then i fell in love with
it back then trent was a ranked demon
who went by habib everyone knew he was
an incredible player but some people
thought he was a bit of a troll like i
played with him in ranks before he was
trent um
and i thought he was just kind of like a
funny like dumb ass little kid but
obviously he turned into like some
animal stud that he is he's a very good
player i mean he's a troll so i mean
have been trolling each other in ranks
for the past year but other than that
he's uh he's actually an insane player
trent spent 2021 dumpstering pros and
ranked and trying to make a name for
himself in the tier 2 scene he hopped
around various no-name rosters and
actually put up decent numbers but what
he really wanted was to be recognized by
a top org i probably messaged every team
that didn't have a full five
and i would just tell them like let me
get my opportunity like i'll show you
what i can do
uh xander told me that he egoed a dm
from trench while we when we were on
soar
could have we could we could have picked
up a new talent on store all good no
matter how many dm's trent sent out
nobody was willing to give him a chance
trent was out of luck his reputation as
an online demon made a lot of people
nervous about taking a shot on him just
about every top team ignored his
messages so he kept slumming it in tier
2 valorent but after he finished second
at a night's monthly gauntlet event one
org in particular took notice the guard
were in the middle of building a team to
try to break into tier 1 valorent and
after locking in players for four out of
five roles all that was left was to find
a silva player trent who was known habib
at the time um
we actually scrimmed him at one point
his team and he dropped like 30 on us or
you know 30 or 40 you know something
crazy that i was like this kid's
actually sick
and he was on viper at the time and so
i always joked i was like yo why don't
we give him a shot or whatever and
didn't even know he was a silva player
the guard were the first team that
actually wanted trent partially because
he was based in california just like
them but there were still problems see
trent had just turned 17 which made the
org a little nervous
the guard wanted all their players to be
18 or older and they had to live in the
states but their coach mce didn't want
to limit the team's potential canadian
jonah p joined shortly before trent and
despite his initial hesitation mce knew
that trent had the potential to be
something special so he went against the
org's wishes and signed the players that
he wanted to it turned out that trent
was making waves in tier 2 valor with a
potato pc and mc realized that he would
level up pretty quickly on better
hardware i was like well what kind of pc
do you have and he's like oh yeah i
basically play on a toaster i mean this
kid's like
uh dropping really good numbers on
soviet on agents on a toaster pc on west
coast pink the 17 year old prodigy was
brought in to replace one of esports
most experienced competitors som and
after seeing trent play the guard were
more than willing to take a risk on him
between the two we're gonna take the
more experienced option and every single
time i've done the safe option in my
career it has actually burned me
and so i was like brenda i'm sorry i
would kill myself if i let this kid go
like we have to get this kid trent was
finally on a real team but he needed
practice with his new teammates fast so
the guards started grinding smaller
events and even picked up a win at an
nsg open can now we see a clutch from
nerve a three versus one the al jonas
spot him good luck have fun
recon on top of that
and now he's just been through grounded
absolutely surrounded the guard they
finally pull it through you could almost
just see it coming when it started when
they started clawing back on defense and
then they finally win it out in overtime
the guard looked solid against tier 2
competition but nobody really knew what
to expect from them when they went up
against the region's top teams once vct
qualifiers got underway though trent and
the guard made a name for themselves as
some of na's best
watching for anyone jumping out of
garage here jonathan gets that contact
trent here to support the two players
not looking the right way it's a nice
easy mop up here for the guard as they
get all five cosmic divided on the
defender's side he's trying to hold back
towards the sidewalk a lean out for the
first game
and it's gonna be the guard winning this
13-7 and trent the clutch player for the
red bull clutch
guard earned this there was a story of
being able to bring a team together for
for a really long time now and just make
sure that it was a team that gelled and
they have gelled themselves into the vct
the guard made it into vct through the
first open qualifier and the whole time
trent was all anyone could talk about
after only a couple months with the team
he was already clutching important
rounds
trent showed that despite being one of
valeran's most cracked zoomers he was
also one of the most disciplined players
in the game he was playing valerian at
an incredibly high level something you
don't see from a lot of young
up-and-comers he has very good aim he's
a smart guy for his age
i mean you can't you don't see many
people
with the way he thinks at his age or 17.
usually they're like more aim
dependent but he has a good aim and he
has a good way of thinking about the
game so
he's a very good player and it was a
good pick up for the guard the guard
ended up in a tough group for vct up
against big names like c9 x-set and
hundred thieves everyone knew that the
guard were good but up until then they
hadn't really played any of na's premier
teams no one knew if the guard could
beat their more experienced opponents
but once it was time to play
trent made a statement
oh
oh my trends
now in a 1v3 has some space has double
shocks oh trying to line up some shots
off the ghost but he's not able to hit
anything ethan already has
strikes down ethan with a red bull
clutch trent keeps the guard on top
all three players now for a hundred
thieves trying to come out in the middle
of sight one person coming up from cat
there goes the drop from eccles trent
and valinol getting killed a 4v1 a
statement from the guard 13-0
over a hundred thieves
the guard won their opening matches with
ease and trent showed off just how good
he is at spraying the vandal he mastered
to control the weapon in a way that not
many players had
and as the group stage continued trent
and the guard didn't let their foot off
the gas they took down exit and eg to go
4-0
but awaiting them on the last day of the
season was a team that many considered
to be the best in n a
cloud nine just like the guard c9 also
went for on the group stage their
matchup was the clash of nas titans and
the guard
got rolled can cloud9 keep punishing
them as they move forward still five
players strong now as the push finally
comes through but great position here
from mitch the bait the fright click is
the heart of the quad kill jonah p's
needs a magical clutch here a miraculous
clutch takes down the first player two
more to go now the ice lane is one one
seven bullets but zetta sprays it on
through with the bulldog and cloud9
answer back after that first map and
it's up to side player 33 health the
play store comes three has to connect he
has to connect there's no choice they
can't do anything but then for zipper
takes him down and there's nothing left
at all and cloud9 they've done it sean
they've defeated the guard they've
destroyed their 13 13-0 streak
both teams traded blows by winning each
other's maps but map 3 was a disaster
for the guard c9 solidified their spot
as the number one team in their group
and as na's number one team the guard
went into playoffs looking for revenge
but first they had to face a new
challenge
sentinels had a pretty shaky group stage
but they were still sentinels the
reykjavik champions and the most popular
team in the game with tens finally
playing on a lower ping it seemed like
he was gonna pop off and wipe the floor
with the guard but the guard slaughtered
them luckily his life is saved to 3v2 in
favor of the guard tenza is gonna have
to make a play happen again he's done it
once before he's gonna be on the
sideline this time as trick gets for a
thrifty round win for the guard as they
take the lead not done quite yet but
they can taste it victory just on the
other side
they're only three players make that two
standing between the guard and a 13-1
win on ice box in a 2-0 sweep of
sentinels in the opening round
of this playoff tournament and
as quickly as it started it ended i want
to say in the last four or five rounds
of the series ender there were there
were prime gaming but there were
flawless rounds right it
it was that bad after dominating
sentinels the guard crushed lg to earn a
spot in the upper bracket finals against
optic oh here we go everyone's just
full-headedly pushing forward jonah for
the first nat able to trade out one
v-dog still with knives on towards the
side an opportunity to try to continue
to put the pressure forward but the
problem is he's by himself would have to
do something unbelievable and is nearly
good for it it's just the pistol left
the right click's not going to convert
and that will do it
and it's just it's
what do you say man it is too many
advantages thrown away i think lg
planned correctly they just could not
convert let's take a step back here
trent was just 17 years old he'd only
been playing with his team for a couple
of months and here he was already
playing for a spot in his first ever
international land against some of the
best teams in the world unfortunately
the card got embarrassed
it's still victor on the top of the
scoreboard so he's kind of been a silent
killer and as you have a silent killer
he gets an opening kill into hookah
showstopper into the side it connects
out to fallon jonah p with a guardian in
the back a flank from net a 1v1 jordanp
gets the headshot but he finally falls
by the hands of gay now up to net he
falls down as well and soya player is
gonna have to try to clutch at 3v1 he
does get those two kills but that's not
enough the envious of the green wall
optic gaming is the first team for north
america going to iceland a neon pit
caught them by surprise on map one and
before they knew it the series was over
this left the guard with one last chance
to qualify for iceland but to do it
they'd have to take down the team that
beat them on the final day of the group
stage cloud nine going to the match
trent knew that it wasn't gonna be easy
i definitely think cloud9 is the best i
think optic played really well today but
overall like cloud9 is is just solid
like all their plays like everything
they do is really good i definitely
think cloud9 is the best team finally in
a position to put him away for zeta full
17-15 the guard holds serve as close as
it was as they take care of ice box and
take the lead in this best of five my
goodness well i didn't think that map
was gonna end
he's backside he's in a world of hurt
felon
oh believe what the show stopper from
evan finds one and that's all it is
mitch is alone in this one v3
can they keep them back an excellent
opener out of messiah assaya gets a
second
oh it's all over that's it baby pack
your bags from rookies to reykjavik the
guard are headed to masters
everyone knew the guard could win but no
one expected them to annihilate c9 with
a 3-0 victory but trent wasn't done yet
with an extra twenty thousand dollars up
for grabs and a group stage buy in
iceland the guard wanted revenge on
optic the last time optic took down the
guard guard just showed that they can
learn from defeat against c9 they
bounced back and crushed them 3-0
yesterday and we're going to ascent for
map one blocks out dial drone completely
optic are in but only barely in fact how
about fallon coming through with another
transfer jonah from the side door and
trees able to help involve and it's just
down to crashes what looked like it was
gonna be just a full commit for optic
it's once again stalled by the solo
paranoia and just omen wielding valon
continuing on his hot streak from
yesterday are they really going to find
full clearance here they're trying to
isolate ballon inside the side of the
problem is trent just spams through the
offensive talks to screen for a double
but there's not really the ability for
them to move forward and the guard put
him in a blunder in the back row maybe
even potentially contest marvin on the
site's good yay gonna reveal himself
still holding on to his teammates the
trade's coming back and forth but it's
optic with the numbers three yay two
good from deep
el diablo tries to rendezvous back
but is this a divine comedy for dante's
inferno by saya player 1v1 with crowd
bang
zaya player for the double and as the
green wall crumbles it's five fresh
faces who now stand guard over the north
american region the guard proved that
they're the best in na they took down
every single top team to earn themselves
a spot at their first international land
and the whole time trent popped off
proving that he's one of the best
initiators in the game trent is a
valorant prodigy nobody was willing to
give him a chance but once he finally
got his opportunity he took it and never
looked back
trent proved that he's the real deal and
the card would not be the team they are
today without him yeah that kid's unreal
uh he's a little bit of a idiot
sometimes in real life he only eats like
pizza peanut butter sandwiches but
in-game is really smart player
mechanically talented and like he's all
you could want to team it the guard have
only been playing with trent for a few
months and he's already dominated n a
at only 17 years old trent's future and
valorent might just be brighter than
anyone else's
i think maybe i have to put this
actually over here
nothing too far for me on my hoodie
it's just cat hair on my mic
great